- Hello everybody and
welcome to the first seminar
for the Fall 2020.
Different from what
everybody was expecting,
but glad that we can
somehow carry on with life.
So, today we have Doctor Salma Mousa,
who is a postdoctoral fellow
at the Immigration Policy lab,
and also the Center for Democracy,
Development and the Rule of Law
both at Stanford University.
And Salma is a political scientist.
And she has very broad experience maybe,
and being a barista in several countries.
And she has been studying social cohesion
the concept, the process, and outcome.
And her work has been basically
supported by many advocates,
and has been also widely flair
across the media and yeah.
Today, she is going to present the paper
that was recently,
Published in science on Social Cohesion,
Inter-Group Contact and
Soccer in Post-ISIS Iraq.
So, Salma will speak first,
but obviously if you, I mean,
depending on how she wants, I mean,
we will have time in the presentation
and then the questions
have time for questions.
She can obviously take the questions.
She will be giving the presentation
and will, if she wants,
so maybe she might not see you,
but you can raise your
hands for questions.
So, with that, so I'll just leave you.
Salma.
- Great first, thank you
so much for inviting me.
I've been looking forward
to this for a while.
I'm really excited for the discussion.
So, I'll try to keep the
presentation on the shorter side.
Thanks Ahmed for inviting me
and Theresa for organizing
and thanks to J-PAL and IPA
for funding this project.
So, I'm here to present some
results on Inter-Group Contact
and Social Cohesion in post ISIS, Iraq.
I should say, if you have
clarifying questions,
you can write them in the
chat and hopefully one
of the organizers will
just read them out to me.
If not, you can interrupt
me if they're clarifying.
Otherwise, hopefully we'll have plenty
of time for discussion at the end.
So, let me take you back
to the summer of 2014.
When a lot of us were
horrified to see ISIS take over
large swathes of territory
in Northern Iraq and Syria.
That campaign involved
the ethnic cleansing
of religious minorities,
primarily Yazidis,
but also smaller numbers of Muslim
and Christian groups as well.
Hundreds of thousands of whom
were forcibly displaced
basically overnight
from this orange Iraqi area
you can see on the left
there to the relative safety
of the green Kurdish held area.
Many people thought that this
displacement would just last
for a few days and it was
actually two to three years
before they would return.
And when they did return,
this is what they found.
They found that their
churches, their schools,
their homes had been all but destroyed.
These are two of the biggest
churches in the Christian city
of Qaraqosh in Northern Iraq.
You can see the really heavy damage
from air raids.
ISIS often would just torch
things and just burn them on
their way out when they
were forced out of the city.
A lot of bullet holes everywhere,
and these pictures are
actually pretty recent.
Like this place still looks like this,
even though the city was
liberated two years ago.
And they also found similar
levels of damage to their homes.
So, on the left is a picture
I took in a house in Qaraqosh.
You can see in the top left corner there,
the AC had been pried off the wall.
So, all the valuables were
gone when they came back,
like deeds to their houses, furniture,
really anything that could
be grabbed was grabbed.
And on the floor,
you can see the beginnings of a tunnel
that had begun to be built by
ISIS fighters when they were
being closed in on before giving up
and on the right is another home
that I visited, also
a Christian residence.
And in graffiti, outside their house,
it says the Islamic State will live on.
And maybe naively, I asked the
owners of this house, like,
why would you keep this ISIS
graffiti outside your house?
Like why don't you paint over that?
And they were very
adamant that they were not
gonna paint over it.
And they wanted to preserve
this graffiti as a Testament
to the world of what had happened to them.
And so this experience
is very much ingrained
in the Christian psyche and
in this communal identity,
this kind of collective
displacement experience
and this collective trauma.
And because I think
that the people who live
in these areas can speak for themselves,
maybe better than I can describe it.
I also have a short clip to show you,
and this is it Nomi,
who was actually one of
the study participants
and his mom talking
about their displacement experience,
speaking to a PBS crew
who covered the study.
- Yana is one of thousands
that fled Kadakoosh
as ISIS approached.
(mean speaking foreign language)
Rami's mother thought
they would only be gone for a few days.
(woman speaking foreign language)
- So, I think this shows just a tiny slice
of what these people went through.
And you can imagine that
after this kind of trauma
of that ISIS occupation
just occupying your home
and just living there
and you come home and
that's what you find.
And so that displacement experience
and that very slow process of
return, as you can imagine,
has really devastated
social cohesion in the area,
especially between Christians and Muslims.
So, the Muslims who stayed behind
are seen as being ISIS collaborators,
and those who fled,
even those who were themselves persecuted
because they belonged to
Muslim minority groups.
They're resented for different reasons.
They're seen as encroaching
on the Christian identity of
these areas and diluting
that historically Christian presence.
So, whichever way you slice it,
whether they're seen
as ISIS collaborators,
or even if they are themselves victims,
that shared victim hood,
actually hasn't done much
to improve relations.
And so this leaves us
with a really important policy problem,
which is how can we build social cohesion
after this kind of violence?
And we have a set of tools
that potentially can help,
which is important.
given that backsliding into violence
after the physical fighting
has stopped, is common.
And so these tools can be
categorized as institutional tools
and tools at the grassroots
level very broadly.
So, at the institutional level,
you have things like power
sharing arrangements,
structural protections for minorities.
And then at the grassroots level,
we have programs that try to
improve everyday interactions
between individuals and from
those grassroots programs.
I'm focusing on one, which
is Intergroup contact.
This idea that positive
cooperative contact
across group lines generally
improves Intergroup relations.
is thought to reduce prejudice
and build friendships.
And on the whole,
this is something that's
gonna take the society forward
in terms of social cohesion.
So, in recent years,
we've had a solid causal
evidence-based growing
on this question,
but there's still a
lot that we don't know.
So, it seems generally positive,
but a lot of open questions remain.
From those open questions
we don't know which conditions matter.
So, what type of contact matters?
The original theory says that
contact should be cooperative
and not competitive,
that it should be endorsed
by communal authorities
and norms, and that it should involve
equal power status between participants,
at least within the context
of the intervention,
even if there aren't equal in society
and of these conditions,
we really only have good
causal evidence on one.
We also don't really know
whether contact can affect
real-world behaviors.
So, there's two problems here.
The first is that the vast
majority of contact studies rely
on self-reported attitudes
measured directly
after the intervention.
And so we don't really know
how robust these effects are.
And the second is that
there is an assumption
that's really core to contact theory,
which is that if you improve attitudes
and tolerance toward the contact partner,
so the people who come
together for the intervention
that these positive acts will extend
to members of the out group more broadly.
So, you're now gonna navigate
the whole world differently.
You're gonna treat strangers
from the out group differently,
not just the people that you know,
and the thinking is
that contact is trivial
if the effects are concentrated only
within the people in the intervention,
but this assumption
that seen as really key
to understand the
effectiveness of this tool
and we don't really have systematic tests
between effects toward people
who meet in the intervention
versus more broadly.
And lastly, we don't
have a lot of evidence
for good reasons on contact after,
during or after conflict for good reasons,
because obviously these
settings are hard to do work in,
but also because the
likelihood of negative contact
or contact experience becoming negative
is probably higher in these settings.
And we do know that negative contact
disproportionately shapes
prejudice as opposed to positive contact.
And so the expectations
can go either way here.
You could think baseline
tolerance is pretty low,
so there's a lot of room for improvement.
On the other hand,
you might also think that prejudice
is particularly sticky in these settings.
Given that we do know that prejudice
is sticky among adults among those
who have been exposed to violence
and when the type of
prejudice deals with ethnic
or religious identities,
as opposed to prejudice toward the elderly
or the disabled, for example,
which is easier to shift
and all of these conditions
are true in my particular setting.
So, what I'm gonna do, or what
I did do, is hold constant,
these optimal conditions of
contact as much as I can.
So, this is pretty rough,
but generally this should be
a positive contact experience
via soccer, and team
sports naturally meet a lot
of the criteria I just mentioned.
So, it's cooperative.
You have this equalizing
effect of playing on a team
in terms of power status.
And the leagues were supported
by Christian leaders,
and I'm gonna hold
constant those conditions
and then test contact in
a post-conflict setting
and see whether a contact can
change real world behaviors.
So, can contact build tolerance after war
and if so, do those effects extend outside
of the intervention?
And so the research question
is can contact build tolerance,
attitudes, and behaviors after war?
And to preview the main result.
I found that contact improved
everyday tolerant behaviors toward peers,
so toward the guys
within the intervention,
but it did not necessarily
build broader social cohesion
outside of it.
So for he rest of the talk,
I'm gonna outline the research design,
and then I'm gonna dive
straight into the main results.
I'll discuss a couple of
interesting mechanisms
and then touch on
potential backlash effects,
which are really important in this setting
and show how I ruled those out.
And then I want to open it up actually
to get us talking in the discussion
about trying to understand this pattern
of results and the implications,
and then I'll end by
discussing how much I think
the setting generalizes to
other settings and takeaways
from an academic and policy perspective.
So, jumping into the research design.
So, the aim of this study was
to build Christian
tolerance toward Muslims.
If you are familiar with the Middle East,
this might seem a little bit backwards.
Like the broader social challenge
is improving Muslim
regard toward minorities
who do tend to be
stigmatized and marginalized.
The reason why I focus on Christians
for this study is twofold.
The first is that it's just practical.
I had access to this community
through my NGO partners
and they formed the majority
in these study sites.
And then the second reason is that there
are anticipated benefits
to building social
cohesion within displaced,
among displaced people.
So, this seemed like something
that was worth doing.
And especially given that
Christians are the majority
in these areas, you still have in a way,
this more traditional dynamic
of attitudes toward minorities.
So, the sample consisted
of 42 entirely Christian soccer teams
across two study sites.
And so how this worked
was that I partnered
with this Christian Iraqi
Christian community organization,
and we invited all of
the teams in the area,
which are almost entirely
divided by religion.
And we invited all the
Christian teams in the area
to sign up for these leagues.
And we really hyped it up.
Like these leagues are gonna be awesome
and the fields are new and
there's gonna be bleachers
and people in the stands and trophies
and professional referees and
new uniforms and all of that.
And so actually all of the teams
who were invited actually
accepted the invitation.
And so once they were recruited,
they then did a baseline survey
and based on their responses
to a baseline survey item
on empathy toward Muslims,
I did a block randomization
at the team level.
So, I took the team's average
response to this baseline item
on empathy, and then ranked the teams.
And then all the two closest
teams kind of just paired
them one after the other,
and then did this coin
flip to block randomize
at the team level in that way.
So, this is what the treatment
actually looked like.
So, what happens if you
randomized the treatment?
So, on the left, you can see
that the control group received
additional Christian players
and the treatment group received
four additional Muslim players.
And this holds constant the experience
of having new players added to your team.
So, these are preexisting teams
and they either get new Christian players
or new Muslim players.
And these Christian Muslim players
who are added are themselves
drawn from the rosters
of teams who weren't
included at that first step.
So, they didn't respond to the invitation,
or they were like just a little bit
outside the geographic area,
or they were free agents,
or they weren't associated with a team.
And so we're holding
constant this experience
of training with a new player
who should be somewhat on
your level in terms of skill,
because they're already
playing and practicing
with other teams.
And so the randomization
happens at two levels.
The first is your treatment status,
which is at the team level,
and then a conditional being
assigned to receive Christian
or Muslim players, those
individuals on your team,
they were also randomly assigned.
So, this left me with four
leagues of roughly 14 teams each
across these two study sites
and the teams trained together
and they competed for a two month league.
If you add up these training
hours and the playing hours,
they met maybe like two
or three times a week
for about two months.
And so it was a league format.
So, every team played each
other. It was like a round Robin.
And then the teams with the
most points then advanced
to this knockout stage
of playing in the finals.
- [Man] Sorry, Salma, I just
needed some clarification.
So, you just said, okay,
so the randomization at
the team level is whether
or not you get Christian
players or Muslim players added.
And then you said the conditional on that,
the specific individuals
are randomized as well?
I don't understand, okay,
how that affects the research design
or what kind of inferences
we can make from that.
- It doesn't affect the-.
It's more just to have some,
to feel a little bit more comfortable
that these guys who are
being added to the team.
So, it's kind of part of the treatment
like who you're actually meeting.
That there's no reason to think that like
having Muslim players added
to your team would mean
they were systematically
better for example,
than the Christian players.
So, we get that inference from
randomized, from recruiting
those added guys in the same way.
So, they were from these rosters of teams
who weren't included at the first level,
and then just randomizing
the particular individuals.
Like it's not really that super important
to the research study.
It's just to,
hopefully the distribution of skills would
be like somewhat even across the teams.
And that is actually what we found
when I look at the baseline ratings
of the skill as rated by the RAs.
Yeah, so, who are these guys?
So, the median player is 23, unemployed,
not married and has a maximum
of a high school degree
in terms of inter-group attitudes,
they have few to no Muslim friends.
They would not be willing
to sell land to Muslims
and they would not want to
have a Muslim as a neighbor.
How do they compare to
the general population
of displaced Christians?
So, here I'm comparing the study sample,
their baseline responses with a survey
of just over a thousand
displaced Christians,
which I supervised in the
area around the same time
as the first study wave.
And so it seems generally
like along these items,
like on the left here, you can see,
are you proud to be Iraqi?
Do you think coexistence is possible?
Do you think Muslims are welcoming?
Would you sell land to Muslims?
They're a little bit,
they're pretty similar to
the general population.
If anything, they're a
little bit less tolerant,
a bit less likely to want to sell land
and view Muslims as being welcoming.
So, touching back on the research design.
So, we have this group
of guys they're about
to start these leagues.
So, how do I actually
know if this is gonna work
and how do I know more importantly,
if the effects of contact
will extend off the field?
So, I categorize my outcomes first,
there's behavioral and
there's attitudinal.
And within the behavioral outcomes,
I look at on the field and
off the field behaviors,
which is supposed to
roughly map onto tolerance
toward the guys who you know,
and then tolerance toward Muslim strangers
outside the intervention.
So, starting with the
on the field behaviors,
the three behaviors I measure first,
how likely are you to register
for a mixed team next season?
The second is whether you
vote for a Muslim player who
is not on your team to
receive a sportsmanship prize.
And this award is really stressed
as being about sportsmanship,
not about skill,
and if anything is actually
mechanistically biased in favor
of choosing a Christian player,
because you can't pick
someone on your team.
And so the guys on the treated teams,
there were like four Muslims
who they couldn't select from.
So, it was a shorter
list of Muslims to pick.
And lastly, I look at
whether you are training
with Muslims six months later
after the intervention ended,
and those Muslims could be
the guys who were assigned
to your team,
or it could be from the
neighborhood in general,
the majority who were still training
with Muslims six months later,
were training with those who
were assigned to their teams.
So, these are my set of outcomes
to reflect kind of this internal tolerance
and moving to off the field tolerance,
I capture three behaviors
that should measure behaviors
toward Muslim strangers
and how comfortable you are
toward Muslims you don't know
outside the intervention.
So, the first is whether you
attend a mixed social event.
So, this was like a neighborhood event
that was put on by the league organizers.
And we made it very clear that
this was an open invitation
to everyone in the neighborhood
and that the Muslim
players would be coming,
but also other Muslims from the community
and that they could
also bring their family
and they could bring guests.
And so it was very clear
that this reflected the
prospect of meeting Muslims
who you didn't know necessarily,
and actually in the first study wave,
this event coincided with Ramadan
fast breaking meal, Iftar.
So, it was even more salient for people
that Muslims would be
coming to this event to eat.
And just so if you're curious
what this event actually
looked like, here's like a little snippet.
(video droning)
(upbeat music)
(people speaking foreign language)
So, it was a dinner and
dancing and traditional dancing
and some other games and
prizes were given out
but it was not advertised
as a league event.
It was advertised as this community event.
The second behavior capturing
off the field behaviors
is whether you patronize
a Muslim owned business
in a Muslim part of town.
So, can a contact
overcome these structural
obstacles to social cohesion,
things like social segregation?
And so what I did was I had these coupons
and you can see a picture here.
And so we gave all the players
with their unique ID, these coupons,
and these coupons were valid
for a restaurant in Mosul,
which is a Muslim dominated city
that's about a 40 minute
drive from the study site.
And it was valid for three
months after the league ended.
And so we then went and
collected these coupons again,
and then saw who actually
showed up cause it was stamped
with their unique ID.
So, are you more likely
to go to this Muslim town,
which was actually seen
as the unofficial ISIS capital in Iraq?
So, it was very much associated,
psychologically speaking with,
I guess like Muslim extremism
or generally like not very
friendly toward Christians
in the minds of the participants.
And then lastly,
do you donate your $1 survey compensation
to the church or do you donate it
to a neutral NGO that serves
both Muslims and Christians?
So, some of the examples
given more like orphanages
and cancer charities versus the church.
And then for attitudes, I have
eight items in the survey,
which I measure at baseline
and at the end line,
which took place about a
month after the intervention.
And I use this hierarchical
clustering model to collapse
these eight items into three indices.
And so I've labeled these
indices, national unity.
So, this consisted of items
like we should treat each other
as Iraqis first and ethnic
and religious boundaries are arbitrary.
The second index I label Muslim blame.
So, how likely are you to blame
these various Muslim civilian groups
for Christian suffering?
And then lastly,
would you want to have
any of these Muslim groups
as your neighbor?
So, I'll pause in case
anyone has further questions
before I dive right into the main results.
Okay so, diving straight
into the main results.
So, here I'm showing you
predicted probabilities adjusted,
covariate adjusted for the
six outcomes I just described.
So, first comparing the means
for treatment and control.
So, if we look at the, on
the field outcomes first,
so training with Muslims,
voting for a Muslim to
receive a sportsmanship award
and registering from
mixed team next season,
we consistently see
these significant positive
treatment effects.
And then when we move to
the off the field outcomes.
So, do you visit this Muslim restaurant
in another part of town?
Do you go to this mixed social event?
Do you donate
your compensation to a mixed
NGO as opposed to the church?
There's not much movement there at all.
So, this suggests that contact
seems to be effective for on the field
or internal tolerance,
but it at least seems to struggle
in this case to generalize
to other social settings
and looking at the attitudinal results.
They're not displayed here,
but of the three indices.
I didn't see much movement
on Muslim neighbor
or Muslim blame, but I
did see this positive,
pretty chunky effect of
the national unity index.
So, it was very abstract
ideas about ethnic divisions
being arbitrary and the
need to treat each other
as Iraqis first.
But when you ask about really concrete,
inter-group attitudes questions,
like how do you feel about Muslims?
We don't really see a change, which again,
seems to suggest that I'm
looking at this generalized
treatment of Muslims didn't really move,
but the guys who you
met in the intervention,
that that was more malleable.
So, are these two classes
of outcomes on the field
and off the field we see here that
there seems to be a pattern,
but can we actually test
these against each other?
So, here's an exploratory analysis
that I did trying to answer that question.
So, what I did here was I estimated
six new average treatment effects.
So, first I look at the
treatment effect of engaging
in at least in one on the field behavior
and then the treatment effect
for engaging on one
off the field behavior.
And then I test those
two against each other.
And then I do the same
for whether you engage
in two on the field behaviors
or two off the field,
find those two ATEs, test
those against each other,
and then do the same
for all three behaviors.
So, once I do that and I'm able
to actually directly
compare the on the field
and off the field behaviors
and do this difference in difference.
So, the two difference
in difference groups here
being first treatment and control,
and the second level of differences
on the field versus off the field,
there does seem to be this pattern
that actually seems to be
statistically significant,
that your contact does actually make you
more likely to engage in on the field
as opposed to off the field behavior.
So, this pattern seems to be robust,
in just that first viewing.
- [Man] Can I ask a question?
- Yes.
- [Man] Can you hear me?
- [Man] Actually I have two questions
on this aspect of the analysis.
I guess I don't fully understand the way
you do the hour on the
field, off the field.
The more natural procedure
would have been, you know,
maybe there is some sort of latent factor
which represents on the field behavior.
You have six markers of it and
you do a factor analysis on
those and you do something similar
for the other type of behavior.
And so I don't fully
understand this one or two,
like why is that the most
efficient way of doing it?
The other one is more substantive.
So, this is a technical
suggestion at this point.
Maybe you can improve that.
The other one, I don't
see what you're mentioning
with this difference,
this probably my common
lack of understanding of these things,
but so why is it interesting
to look at that the differences
in these two factors in these two,
like in variables on the
field, off the field?
- Yeah, sure.
So, I think this factor analysis,
I think that's also
another technique I'm open
to exploring different ways
of getting at this question.
This is kind of a way that I came up with,
I'm sure there are
others what I think works
about this approach.
So, just to maybe elaborate
on the motivation.
So, just going back to this,
the plot for the main results,
usually you see a plot where like,
let's say you have a pattern
of null results somewhere
and then results somewhere else.
And we usually just leave it at that.
Like we see a pattern
here and a pattern here.
And so I wanted to take it a step further
and test those patterns
against each other,
to understand if they're significant
when you test them against each other.
And going back to the theory, like,
you know, why am I doing this study?
One of the core motivations
is to know whether contact works just
for the people who you know,
like these known contacts,
or does it actually have the potential
to unlock this broader
cohesion towards strangers?
And so it's good to know
that there's a pattern
of null results here and it
seems more effective here,
but to be able
to test those two things
against each other,
I think provides more
information for getting
at that core question of
whether effects generalize.
Yeah, I think there's plenty
of ways of doing this.
I like the idea of doing well,
obviously I like it because I did it.
I liked the idea of classifying
the outcomes in terms
of engaging in one or more behaviors,
two or more, just descriptively
like this panel on the left.
I think it's interesting to
see like the distribution
of how many of these
outcomes people engaged in.
I think another way of
doing it would be pairwise,
like compare all of the
on the field outcomes and all
of the off the field outcomes
and compare them all against each other
without classifying them in this way.
I just thought this was
kind of a neat structure
to understand a little bit
descriptively what was going on.
So, like you can see
for all three behaviors,
like very few people engaged in those.
Like it's kind of a sanity
check that these magnitudes
are going in same direction as
we're kind of asking more of
the participants at each step.
Yeah, but I think there's
other ways of doing it.
I think factor analysis would work too.
- [Man] Thanks.
- Yeah. Thank you.
Okay, we seem to see here
that contact is effective,
at least for some behavioral outcomes,
more mixed effects for
attitudes and no effects
for off the field outcomes or how people
are behaving toward Muslim strangers.
So, why could that be the case?
So, here are some secondary
analysis that I ran,
mapping out what does
the literature tell us
in terms of generating
expectations about mechanisms?
And so two of the mechanisms
that loom really large
in the contact literature,
the first is that contact
might provide more information.
And I don't find evidence for that.
So, the treatment had no effect
on information about Muslims
and when you also break
apart the treatment effects
by subgroup and look at those
who had like low versus
high baseline information.
I also don't see anything happening there.
So, it doesn't seem to be the
key factor in this setting.
The second mechanism in the literature
is that contact might induce empathy.
And similarly, I don't find
evidence for this here either.
So, again, looking at
empathy as an outcome,
or whether you look at
heterogeneous treatment effects
by baseline empathy, I also
don't see a difference there.
I do find some evidence
for two other mechanisms.
So, a mixture of qualitative
and quantitative evidence.
The first is that having a
positive experience seems
to be important.
So, being on a team that ends up
being successful seems to be important
for amplifying treatment effects.
And lastly, it seems to be that contact
was changing norms around
the accessibility of contact,
both among players and among residents.
So, all right.
- [Alex] Can I just ask you, does,
does the treatment effect
the success of the teams?
- I was just waiting
for this I'm like, yes.
Alex is gonna ask me if it
team's success is post treatment.
(Alex laughs)
- Yes please! Is it post treatment?
- Yeah, so, on the one
hand, the treatment status
doesn't actually correlate
with your success.
So, it doesn't seem like
being on mixed teams made you play better.
When I also rerun this analysis,
looking at when I
instrument for team success
with baseline skill rating of the players,
I also see similar results.
But yeah, I think it's
kind of in a gray area.
I think it is post-treatment
in that the actual playing
together happened post-treatment
but I think it's kind
of part of the bundle,
so if you wanna-.
- [Alex] Yeah, it is
not true that the teams
that got four extra Christian
players scored more goals
or won more games?
- Right.
- [Alex] Or had fewer
penalties, or whatever.
- Yeah, so actually I
don't have it in here,
but in the paper I look
at success in three ways.
So, first, like the number
of points your team scored,
secondly, the skill rating of the players
and third was the number
of goals scored and actually
on all three of those,
just doing a T test between
treatment and control,
there doesn't seem to be a difference.
Yeah, so, and actually I'll
get into this in a second.
So, I'll just dive in
now to this team success
and also these changing
norms around contact.
So, starting first with
this changing norms.
So, it seemed from this
observational evidence
that at least in the very,
very limited, I guess,
the level of just the norms
around training with Muslims,
like actually playing soccer with people
who are not Christian,
like this very basic thing
that didn't really used to happen before
these leagues seems to have shifted.
So, here's a quote from one of
the Christian players saying,
you know, honestly, before this league,
you would never see Muslims
playing with a Christian team.
Like this is the first time.
And this is reflected in
the baseline data as well.
So, of the total of 51 teams in the study,
only two of them at baseline said
that they regularly train with Muslims.
Another, I said, when the game
was over, we hug and kiss,
even when we lose, that
was really a huge thing.
So, these micro gestures
of just being friendly
were things that were actually
not normalized before we took these steps
to actually integrate the teams.
And again, because I think the players
can describe it better than I can,
a short clip of some of
the players themselves.
The first guy is actually
a Christian team captain.
And then the other is a Muslim goalkeeper.
(man speaking foreign language)
So, it seemed at least among the guys
who knew each other and they met
and some friendships
grew out of this in ways
that would be predicted
by the contact hypothesis.
And I also have some suggestive evidence
of spillover effects
among local residents.
So, here on the left,
you can see a picture
of a league game.
And so these really drew a lot of crowds.
This was also in the first wave
before we got the funding
to upgrade the fields.
So, just don't judge me on the AstroTurf,
but a lot of people came out to these,
like there were hundreds of people.
And so I ran this survey of
about 150 local residents
like randomly selected.
And we asked them about their
exposure to the leagues,
which I measured in a few ways.
So, do you live within
walking distance of a field?
Did you go to the final game,
which had a lot of fanfare and TV crews
and the prize ceremony,
do you have a family or a friend playing
on the teams and how
many games did you attend
if you attended games?
So, these are obviously
completely correlational,
so maybe more tolerant people
actually show up to the games,
but there does seem to be some
kind of positive correlation
between your exposure to the leagues
and your inter-group attitudes.
So, this first plot here,
so looking first on the X axis,
if you attended the final game,
it seems like the people who attended
had a more positive view
of the league's impact
on their community than those
who didn't come to the final.
And we invited everyone
in the town to show up,
and then this was asked
actually three months
after the final.
And then the plot on the
right just looks at going
from I think the second or no,
the first to the fourth quartile
in terms of games attended
and looking at what your likelihood
of saying that you support
future inter-group programming
in the town.
So, the examples that were given
were women's volleyball
tournament's and gardening clubs.
So, again, totally correlational.
But I think it's important
that this highlights
that spill over effects and
these peripheral effects
that happen outside of the
specific contact intervention
are really important
if we care about amplifying
the impact beyond
just the specific people
in the intervention,
especially since it seems
like even among those people,
it doesn't necessarily seem to be the case
that contact effects generalized.
So, we're trying to think like engineers,
how to amplify the impact
of this intervention
that only touches a very
small number of people.
So, moving on to team success.
So, I touched on this earlier,
but it really seemed to be
important that if you played
on a successful team and if the Muslims
on your team played well,
that this had an impact
on how people viewed the entire endeavor.
And so I got thinking about
this when on the sidelines,
like the Christian guy was on the bench
and he saw the Muslim player
on one of the teams
score like a hat trick.
And he just turns to the research
team or the league staff.
And he's like,
why didn't you give us a
Muslim that plays like that?
Like instead of, you know,
points like the Christian guy on his team
who doesn't play like that.
And so effects really,
I wouldn't say they're
contingent on the Muslims
on your team not sucking,
but it definitely helps to
have a similar skill level
so that you don't build resentment.
And so here,
I'm just breaking out the effects
of playing on a successful team,
just among the treated group.
And this is just a really
simple difference in means.
So, again, looking on the
X, zero and one just means,
are you on a successful team or not?
And I'm measuring success
by reaching the finals.
So, did you reach the knockout stage?
You were like the best in your league.
And then on the Y I'm
showing just the proportion
of people on the treated
teams who did that outcome.
So, there seems to be
this consistent pattern,
even on outcomes that
reflect generalized tolerance
of playing on a successful team.
And this pretty much across the board,
when you formalize this a little bit more
like in the covariate adjusted model,
you see the same thing.
So, it seems like the
successful teams really did
have amplified effects.
- [Alex] Sorry, you
mentioned that you also,
it's Lushvig's first question.
What was going on with that
individual random assignment?
So, this is what's going on
with the individual
random assignment, right?
Is that you're basically
getting a random draw,
whether you got the good
ones or the bad ones.
And I guess I'm interested in,
in order to understand this conditioning.
So, like how much of,
how much did the skill
of the players vary?
Like how much worse was the worst set
of four than the best set of four?
- Yeah, so, how I'm trying to get a skill
is like looking at the
number of goals scored
by added players and by the skill rating,
like how RAs rate their skill
and maybe they seem to be balanced,
but you still do have individuals
that can end up being stars in other ways.
Like those two measures
are obviously imperfect.
So, you might have like
a really good defender,
or a really good goalkeeper,
and then that wouldn't be measured
in one of those metrics, for example.
So, I think you do have individual stars
and maybe there's a way to look at people
on those extremes
rather than just look at the average level
of the players who were added,
that actually I think
is a really good idea.
Yeah, maybe something like goals contested
as a measure for like defenders
and to look at like the star, star players
and look at where they, so the
top, like three goals scores,
what team they were on or something
to get at more of the extreme variation.
- [Man] So, this relates
to an important external validity point.
Let's hope my internet
connection holds up.
So, in South Africa, you know,
traditionally cricket and
rugby have been white sports,
especially cricket I know well
and whereas soccer has been
a primarily black sport
and the cricket board has tried hard
to integrate more and have
more black players come in.
And so they've actually had the equivalent
of affirmative action in order
to get more black players
in through the ranks.
And that's actually
created a lot of resentment
because they were on
average, not as good, right?
And there was a lot of
resentment about white players
who were like, no, we try hard,
and we try to, you know,
we practice a lot and we try to get good
and then we don't make the teams
and we don't earn as much money.
- That's exactly right.
I think one of the reasons
why this league had so much
buy in and such little dropout is
because we made it really competitive
and really prestigious
and really attractive,
and people were really
invested in doing well.
And so regardless of the
religious background,
like they want to win.
And so the flip side of that
is that I think you have
to make sure where there's
some minimum level of skill
or else you will get,
I think you will expect backlash effects
and you will expect
resentment because you're
like a net negative in
these people's lives.
And so I think it's already, I mean,
one of the drawbacks as well
of using pre-existing teams
is that they have this, like,
they're much more tight knit.
And so when you add a new player,
you already have that risk of resentment
at having someone come in,
who they haven't chosen when everyone else
on their team has,
they're like a tightly run machine
they've been training each other,
they know each other well,
and now you're throwing
in this random person.
So, that's one of the drawbacks.
Another way to do this study would be
to randomly construct the teams.
Like you actually put the
teams together from scratch,
where this might not be as
much of an issue potentially,
but then you get less buy in I think.
- [Alex] Does this kinda respond
to any of Allport's conditions?
This like need that your
person that you're cooperating
with has to be any good at it?
It seems like a new
condition that you're adding
to the Contact Hypothesis,
which is like, good.
We should move past all of it,
like we haven't, I don't know.
We haven't like tested all
four of the conditions.
So, is this a fifth one?
- I mean, I think his original
conditions are reasonable,
but I think it's not
like, you know, the Bible
or the Quaran, you know,
we can move past it.
So, I think for any endeavor
where like the outcome matters
and there's a stake in it,
and it's something that's, skill-based,
I think you have to have
some minimum amount of skill.
Does that map onto like, having
the experience be positive?
I think that's part of it, but
it could be something deeper.
Like it could be related
to like the actual outcome,
like success in a more objective
sense, rather than just,
did you have fun doing it?
And success doesn't map
perfectly onto having fun.
Like maybe it's even just to show
that a successful experience is possible,
like that counters people's stereotypes.
Like I think it could reflect
a lot of things, but yeah.
I mean, if it were up to me,
I would add, if it's a skill-based
venture or if it's based
on meritocracy, you should
ensure a minimum level
of meritocracy or else you're
gonna build resentment.
Lushvig, what do you think?
- [Lushvig] So, yeah, I was wondering,
I'm sure you know Matt Lowe's
work at UBC much better
than I do, his experiment was
about randomly constructing
teams, is that right?
Rather than this?
- Yes.
Yeah. So, I think he, yeah,
it's a fantastic study and
I like love when we present
our work side by side.
Yeah. He actually put the teams together.
And I think in that setting,
you had a lot of buy-in for other reasons.
Like, I don't need to tell you like
how much people like cricket
and he set it up to be
like very professional.
And so I think in some
settings it's possible,
and you don't have so much this drawback
of less of an investment, but
in this setting in particular,
I think people just would have, like,
there was already this amateur leagues
and team structure that
was already happening.
And it felt a little bit
unnatural to move outside of that
and ask people to forget about their teams
and start from scratch.
And it was already a very
big ask in this setting
to get them to accept having
Muslim players on their team.
There's a lot of pushback around that.
So, one of the concessions was like, okay,
we keep the teams as they are.
- And then finally Gotham Row's work,
which was on Delhi schools, you know,
where that was natural
variation where low caste kids
or civil class, like disadvantaged kids
were put in these classrooms.
I would love to, after the talk
or like at some point
when you have time to write an op-ed,
it would be great to get a
sense of like a two pager,
you know, what did we
learn from the combination
of all these studies, given
the differences in them?
Like with the combination, of course.
- Yeah, that's a great idea.
I know that J-Pal is asking like,
me and Matt are doing some
kind of like evidence Roundup
about contact, so I think
an op-ed is a great idea.
Yeah, I love the route paper as well
because he does actually
look at real world behaviors
and he also looks at academic
achievement as an outcome,
which I think speaks
to this other question
of how does diversity or
introduce contact effect
like success or these like
measurable attainment metrics.
And I kind of touch on it here,
but it's such an
important question outside
of just the standard
prejudice related outcomes.
Yeah. That's a great idea.
I'm gonna commit myself to doing that.
- [Woman] Stephen had
the question on the chat.
- Yeah, please.
- [Stephen] It wasn't a question.
It was just an observation
that if you're trying to make the parallel
to real societies, then
having pre-existing teams
is a good thing.
- Yeah, it's much more naturalistic,
naturalistic, natural.
It's much less artificial
that these guys are
already playing together.
And then you have the
drawback of maybe a lack
of generalizability or other things,
or you can't really tinker in
the way that you might want.
But yeah, I completely agree.
Like it was as unintrusive as possible.
- I mean, we mentioned
just the original Contact
Hypothesis as well.
So, as I remember most of it
tasks and that were sort of group things
like you all push the
truck together rather
than an individual skills-based thing.
So, that does seem to
be some new dimension.
- Yeah, I mean, I'll
get to this a little bit
at the end in terms of generalizability
and how we should update.
But one of the key Allport's conditions,
from the original hypothesis
is that the contact should be cooperative.
So, it should involve some degree
of cooperation as opposed to competition.
So, if you play against each other,
you're not gonna find these effects,
which is what Matt Lowe
tests very well in his paper.
And then the other condition,
which I never quite figured
out the actual difference,
but there's another condition,
which is that you should be
working toward a common goal.
So, cooperation and having a common goal
are supposed to be like two
of the critical conditions.
- [Lushvig] And, you know,
thinking about policy
implications in other settings
that are consequential, you know,
maybe getting refugees and
the host communities, right.
If they have to do a project
together, like, you know,
getting them to work together towards
like rebuilding efforts or paying both
of them to work in the
same team, this might-.
- Exactly right.
I mean, there's no, there's nothing unique
to contact that suggests that it has
to only be this like
inter-religious prejudice
that can be overcome.
You can easily apply this to like migrants
and refugees, different kinds of refugees,
really any cleavage of
identity-based difference
where that identity is known
by everyone in the room.
There's no reason why it shouldn't work.
And I think that's like the next frontier.
And I know you guys have Sandra
Roseau's presenting soon.
And me and her actually
have a project testing,
a very similar setup in Columbia
with Venezuelan migrants.
And like, is there something different
about having newly mixed
populations as opposed
to these old neighbors
that I have in my setting?
That essentially would change
our expectations, but yeah,
there's really no limits to
it if I may say so myself.
Okay so, I know I want to
leave some time for discussion,
so I'll just dive back in.
So, I explained a little
bit about what happened
with the guys on the treated teams.
And so now I want to touch on
the guys in the control teams.
So, these were guys on
all Christian teams,
can we rule out backlash or
at least large enough backlash
to be detected, given my sample size?
And I want to show that that's the case.
I think it's really important
in these fragile settings
where you have this higher
risk of negative contact
to be very aware of this possibility.
So, the first way I rule out
backlash is looking at team,s
looking at games, this
is match level data.
So, matches that brought
together a mixed team
with an all Christian team
versus matches that brought
together two Christian teams
or two mixed teams.
And the idea is that we
want to rule out that an all
Christian team facing off and competing
against a mixed team,
that they are more
aggressive on the field.
So, it seems to be the case.
So, it doesn't seem to be a difference
in the number of red
cards or yellow cards.
But if you're looking at
Christian versus mixed team
compared to two Christian
teams or two mixed teams.
Using cards here is
some kind of rough proxy
for aggression on the field.
So, like fouls and bad language,
and that kind of thing.
Another way I can rule out backlash
is looking just at the control team.
So, these are the guys
on all Christian teams
and comparing their attitudes over time.
So, their baseline and
their end line surveys,
and there doesn't seem
to be much of a change.
It looks like kind of a wash.
And so this is good.
So, this suggests that
at least they didn't
become like significantly
more prejudice over time.
I can do the same for the
Muslim participants as well.
So, obviously it's a much smaller sample.
So, some of this lack of
precision is just due to that,
but it also seems like there
wasn't like a huge increase in
their prejudice toward Christians
when we look at their end line
compared to their baseline.
- [Lushvig] Hey was there a coach
who was making consequential decisions
on the field, like
substitutes and support?
- Yes.
- [Lushvig] And was that
person typically Christian?
- They were always
Christian, the coaches, yeah.
- [Lushvig] Okay, so then
why not look at outcomes
like the number of amount
of playing time the Muslims
were given versus the
Christian and things like that?
- Yeah, that's a good idea.
We actually had in the
rules of the league,
like when we'd brief the coaches,
we said that they had to have
some kind of equal rotation
and that players had to get
roughly equal playing time.
So, we had this like rotating substitute.
So, these guys were like,
not in the best shape.
So, they had to rotate really regularly.
And it was like a very
high intensity format.
So, that actually turned out
to not be a problem at all.
Like we had like unlimited substitutions,
they were always rotating.
But in general, I think
this is a great idea.
Especially given the importance
of like communal leaders
and norms and endorsing the contact.
The coaches are kind of one
of the key figures in all of
this to make it happen.
- [Lushvig] And the fact that performance
didn't actually, you know,
there was no significant
difference in performance
is actually I would say a positive.
- Yeah. Yeah.
Oh gosh. I lost Lushvig.
- [Lushvig] Got lost again.
- Oh, you're back.
- [Lushvig] Okay. Sorry.
I was saying that like, it
might've been a positive outcome.
- Yeah.
I guess it depends what
your expectations are.
Like if the,
if the counterfactuals that
it would get much worse
and like things would just
spiral out of control then yeah,
it's good, yeah,
so maybe like a null in
this case is a good thing,
but the coaches were actually key.
One thing that we observed
was at the beginning,
when we first integrated the teams,
like the Christian players were speaking
their native dialect, not Arabic.
So, they purposely were like,
excluding the Muslim players.
They wouldn't really sit
next to them on the bench.
Like the players were
feeling kind of excluded.
And I was telling the
research manager, like,
are you sure this is okay?
Like, I feel bad for these guys.
He's like, it's okay.
Just let them train, give
them a week to train.
We'll do an orientation.
And slowly you could see it.
They warmed up to each other.
But the coaches actually had
a key intervention, which is,
they told their players,
this is unprompted from us.
They said, we have to all speak Arabic
from now on we're speaking Arabic
so that way everyone can
understand what's going on.
And that was kind of a turning
point for everything else.
So, I totally agree that like
engaging coaches and seeing,
looking at their decision-making
is really consequential.
So, to wrap up,
so we have this pattern
of results that suggests
that contact effects are really
concentrated among people
who know each other.
And so why could that be the case?
There's a lot of different structures
you could overlay on this result.
So, here are some potential explanations.
One is that it could just
be too much of an ask.
So, it could be like
after the kind of trauma
that these people have experienced,
asking them to then start
trusting Muslim strangers
is just a step too far.
So, for example,
if you look at this young man
in the bottom left corner,
he brought this picture
to one of the final games
of his family member,
I believe was his father
who had passed away in the fighting.
And this was actually quite common.
Like people who would
bring these framed photos
and then on the right,
you see the same guy like
with his Muslim teammate, like joking,
laughing like a few minutes later.
And in his mind, there's no,
there's no disconnect
between those two things.
Like you can still have the views
that you have toward Muslims more broadly,
and the kind of suffering
that you underwent is ingrained in you,
but you can meet people
and learn to trust them
and like them and have
friends from that group.
And you don't necessarily see that link.
And so it might be that these kinds
of grassroots programs need
those structural policy levers,
like things like structural protections
and like real real policy change
to be combined with this grassroots stuff,
to really unlock the positive effects.
Like if he really felt safe,
going to Mosul and he felt safe
going about his day-to-day life,
maybe contact would have a bigger effect.
Secondly, it might be the case that
off the field behaviors
are actually difficult
to compare to on the field behaviors
and that they're more costly.
So, one advantage of this study
is that I'm testing these new set
of real-world behaviors,
but at the same time,
because they're very
natural and realistic,
the drawback is that they're a
little bit less standardized,
so it's hard to compare them directly.
So, for example, going
to Mosul is a bigger ask
than voting for someone
to receive an award
like going to Mosul requires
driving time, getting gas,
going through annoying checkpoints
and that kind of thing.
It might also be that again,
back to my example of this young man,
that the guys who you meet
in the contact setting,
you don't view them as
typical for whatever reason.
So, it kind of is baked into
the theory that in order
for contact to work and
generalize outside the setting,
you should see the people
who you're dealing with
as being typical or else
you're gonna do all sorts
of mental, like self inpretzeling
to say that they are exceptions.
So, if you don't see them as typical,
then why would you generalize?
You don't see these two groups
of people as being the same,
so you're not gonna make any inferences.
And lastly, I find that
within like looking at
kind of zooming out at
all the outcomes I measure,
behaviors and attitudes,
that the results are more
concentrated among behaviors
in general, I saw much more weak
or mixed effects on attitudes.
This actually aligns with other work
from post-conflict settings,
like in Rwanda and between Christians
and Muslims in Nigeria, also
looking at prejudice reduction.
And there seems to be this emerging,
very tentatively an emerging pattern
that in these difficult settings,
it might be actually easier to change
or soften some behaviors rather
than self-reported attitudes,
which might actually be
more difficult to shift.
Or at least if we're changing attitudes,
we're not doing it in a way
that we can reliably measure,
like surveys are already too noisy
and it's another reason why we
should move toward behaviors.
So, we've touched a little
bit on generalizeability.
So, just to consolidate
my thoughts on this,
this was a bundled treatment in many ways.
And the setting itself
was very particular.
What do I think worked well?
I think it worked well
that this was apolitical.
I think it worked well that
this was not like a series
of dialogue discussions
about the conflict itself.
And it was something that
had absolutely nothing
to do with politics or the conflict.
That helps us with the first order problem
of actually getting recruiting people
to agree to an inter-group intervention.
A lot of people are turned off by like,
let's sit around a table and talk it out.
Those interventions have their place
and I think they can be powerful.
But if you're wanting to optimize
for a wide appeal for recruitment,
that might not be the best strategy.
The flip side is that, you know,
I didn't see these changes to attitudes
and in a way it's like, well,
why should I expect them to change,
to update their political beliefs?
Because they didn't talk
about anything political.
So, that potentially might
be a trade-off to consider.
The second condition I
think we worked well here
is that this was endorsed
by communal authorities.
So, this is one of Allport's conditions.
And so here you can see
in the pictures there
that actually a priest
was giving out the awards and on the right
is like a rather horrifying team mascot,
which I did not sign off on,
but he somehow made his way into it.
And he's there taking a
picture with some members
of the Christian armed forces in the area.
So, these guys would regularly
show up at the games.
And I think this was
really important for again,
in that first stage of getting
people to even sign up for
them to know that this was
not gonna be stigmatizing
and that this was fine
and the priests are there
and the police are there
and there's no taboo against doing this,
given that that taboo existed beforehand,
there was no contact happening
when it came to soccer.
And we talked about team success.
I think success is somewhat of a proxy
for a positive experience,
but I think it really
mattered that in general,
like we made these leagues something
that people really cared about
and really enjoyed and listen very closely
when they told us how they
wanted the leagues to look.
And it helps us as researchers, right?
People don't drop out. So, it's great.
And so I think this
all these conditions can be
generalized to other settings.
And those include things like
classrooms, dorms, military,
if you have conscription and workplaces,
and there does seem to be
this causal evidence coming
out on all of these types
of settings, where they do find
positive effects of contact.
So, lastly, I hope that I've showed
you some causal evidence
from a difficult setting
that cooperative contact
can build every day social cohesion
and improve everyday
interactions after war.
It did seem to improve relations
and behaviors between friends
and acquaintances and peers
who met in the intervention.
But I did find that transformative change
was more difficult.
So, those effects did not
necessarily extend to strangers.
And so taking a step back if we want,
like we can't do these contact
programs everywhere, right?
So, how can we get the
biggest bang for our buck?
Two suggestions here.
One is to look more at spillover effects.
So, this analysis I did at
the local residents suggests
that there's something going
on with like being exposed
or there could be something
going on with being exposed
on the periphery of this contact
and seeing it happen and
that being normalized
and those effects extending to you.
So, that's one option.
And the other way to amplify the effects
of contact could be pairing it
with like a deeper level policy tool.
So, it just might not be enough to focus
only at the grassroots level,
if there are these glaring
like structural inequalities
that are happening outside
of the intervention.
Another that I don't have
on here is also your,
if you have limited resources,
who should you target for
this kind of intervention?
Obviously, these guys were
all, these were all guys.
There were a lot of
particularities about this case
that meant that it would have
been like very difficult,
if not impossible to have
inter-group contact with women.
But the upside of that is that it seems
at least anecdotally, that
men shape the social norms
in this setting.
And they kind of decide what's okay
and what's not okay in terms of
what public spaces you can be in
and who you can be friends with.
And so if you want your
bang for your buck,
you might want to target
the specific individuals
who might have more of an
influence in that community,
and then make sure you get
buy-in from the leaders as well.
Actually, most of our games
happened on church fields,
like the fields that were
stuck to the churches
and so that was really important.
And so if I have one
takeaway that I want you
to leave this presentation with,
it's that contact has a lot of potential,
but we really need to start
measuring real-world behaviors
to know what that potential
actually looks like.
And we shouldn't necessarily
take it for granted
that these effects will
always extend to strangers.
And that might be okay in some settings,
maybe in this very fragile setting,
you can't expect to build
social broader social cohesion.
And this localized cohesion is enough
to actually build resilience
against future shocks to tolerance.
That's an open question.
And so lastly, going back
to this like classic
literature on social capital,
it seems like it might be
time to revitalize the promise
of these cross cutting
civic organizations,
which may actually have
been so promising initially,
because they included this
kind of inter-group contact,
even though the original framers might not
have used that language.
And so there's a natural bridge
to be built between those literatures.
Okay. That's all I have.
And I'm really looking forward
to your comments and feedback,
and I have a bunch of contact
and other prejudice reduction
experiments in the pipeline.
And so this is really the time
to have these discussions.
So, thank you.
- [Woman] Thank you very much Salma.
Some more questions?
- [Man] Yeah, I have one.
So, this was super interesting,
thank you very much.
So, you know,
this is a local majority
community the Christians, right?
Interacting with the local minority,
the Muslims in a state that's historically
been ruled by Muslims.
And so one question is just about whether
you would expect things to
work similarly elsewhere
with Shiite, Sunni or
Muslims and Christians
in areas where the local
majorities or minorities
were different within even
the same state or whether you
would expect things to
work very differently.
I mean, these might be some of the things
you've got in the pipeline.
I don't know.
- Yeah so, I think the power dynamics here
were kind of quirky.
I think it's another reason I
didn't have it outlined here,
but one reason for this pattern
of results might also be
that Christians are at the national level,
in the national context are
persecuted and targeted.
And so we do have some
contact work that shows
that when you're looking
at people who belong
to minority groups, contact
is less effective for them.
They're just generally much more skeptical
of the whole enterprise
and understandably so.
And so that's where you really
might need the combination
with policy tools to get them on board.
In general, it seems to be easier
for members of the majority
group to reduce their prejudice.
It makes sense.
It's not as consequential
to their like existence.
You know, it's just kind of like, oh,
I met this guy from this
group and he was cool.
Okay. Move on with my life.
Like, it's not so much
of an inter-group threat and anxiety.
So, I think it just makes
the task a bit easier.
So, I would expect that
things would be easier
if I focused on Muslims
as the dominant group.
In terms of other types of cleavages,
like ethnic, Kurdish, Arab,
for example, or within Muslims,
Shiite, Sunni, that I don't
see any theoretic reason
for things to be different for
those particular cleavages,
but that's something I
would love to test out.
And I think it's very
dependent on the on the context
who seems to have the upper hand.
- [Lushvig] I have another comment
or a question or a suggestion.
I think your work is very interesting.
I would like to go back for a second
to your definition of
outcomes and the measurement
that the impact certified.
I can see what you're
trying to do, I think,
and it's good to have
those questionnaires,
but apart from the fact that, you know,
some of your conclusions
might not be that right.
For instance, when you say that there
is a stronger impact on
behavior, rather than ethics,
that could be driven by
the fact that behaviors
might be easier to measure than attitudes.
And so I, A,
I would definitely encourage you
to explore more effective ways to extract
this information from the
data, like (indistinct).
- Can I put this question back to you,
'cause this is something I've
been thinking a lot about.
Can we ever definitively
answer the question,
are behaviors easier
to move than attitudes?
Given that you can't put them on the same,
it's impossible to standardize,
it's a serious question,
'cause it's such a prevalent thing.
- [Lushvig] Well, the
second part of my question
was going partly in that direction.
So, one possibility,
especially given your context should be,
I wouldn't say easy but feasible
is to try to design some
alternative measures based
on games and interactions
among those guys.
Actually, one of my ex
colleagues in London
has been doing some work in Palestine
where she implemented
some cooperation games,
retaliation games among
Palestinians around the wall.
And so you could think of, you know,
at the end of a football
game to make them play
some games that are aimed at
the measuring corporation,
propensity to retaliation,
they can measure attitudes,
and those might provide
because they link up directly
to behavior, to choices,
You might be able to get a more
precise handle on attitudes.
- Yeah, I actually think
that's a good suggestion,
like lab games as being
an intermediate step
between like real-world
behaviors and attitudes,
like something a little bit in the middle,
that's more controlled in
terms of the measurements.
Yeah. But still, yeah.
So, that's a good idea.
- [Lushvig] Yeah. If you want,
I can put you in touch
with the person because-.
- Yeah, please do.
Yeah, I'll follow up.
- [Woman] Alex.
- [Alex] Thanks very much for this site.
You know, I read the paper,
but the presentation really
just walked me through it.
I really, I learned a lot
and I'm really grateful
to you for it.
I wanna, I think this
presentation makes me,
or the study makes me think
about Allport's conditions
a little bit differently.
And one is this cooperation one,
you rightly pointed out, like,
I don't really understand the
difference between cooperating
and working towards a common goal.
Okay, I agree.
I can't really put my finger
on the difference between
that either we could push on it,
but it also you to cooperate,
you need another thing, which
is the ability to cooperate.
Like you can't cooperate with somebody
who can't play soccer.
And so like, it's a funny
subcondition of cooperation
is the capacity to do that.
And I think that may or
may not have been present
in the previous contact
studies, like, all right,
you're in a setting where
you're supposed to cooperate,
but then you have the
capacity to even do so.
If it's the case that you
could only make friends
with people who are good at soccer,
then we've got a bigger problem
than we realized, right?
So, anyway, that's one of the places
that we're pushing
and then the other place
that you brought up, is
like a weakness of the study
but I don't know that it
is a weakness of the study,
the extent to which the Christian players
thought of the Muslim players
as being typical of Muslims.
And like, it's clear
that the condition here
for changing attitudes is
since the attitude object
is the conjured typical
Muslim in your mind.
So, I wonder if in future studies,
there's some measurement stuff
that you could be doing there.
Like, do you think that Muhammad
is typical of Muslims in
your community, right?
And, I would have to
imagine that they'd say, no.
Like, no, Muhammad's my
friend, are you kidding?
Like, so I, but then
are there interventions
that you could deploy
to be like, you know,
your teammates are not so different
from the Muslims in your community.
Like, is there a way to
explicitly draw the links
to increase this typicality
inference that people are doing?
It's just a suggestion for future studies.
- No, this is super interesting.
Like on your first point,
I actually think you
might be onto something.
This ability to cooperate,
yeah you actually might be.
Because thinking about
like some of the studies
that find like negative
or no results on contact
with all the publication
biases we know about
like some are mixed
classrooms in the U.S.,
like these jigsaw classrooms
and the other is the
recent study out of Turkey,
looking at Turkish and Syrian refugee kids
in like a summer camp together.
And in both of those cases,
in the jigsaw classes,
they found that the minority students like
just their ability was lower.
So, or not their ability, but their,
how they performed in the class
was lower than their classmates.
And so jigsaw puzzles means you have
to all work together to solve something
and then it didn't work well,
maybe because it's this
underlying ability.
And the second, like the study in Turkey,
they like the Syrian refugee
kids don't speak much Turkish.
And so it seems like ability
to cooperate in that sense.
Like, you need to speak a language.
Like there are some necessary
conditions for cooperation.
- [Alex] Having the
Christian player switch
to Arabic for crying out loud.
- Exactly. Yeah.
So, I actually think something to that,
like the ability to cooperate
as being something different
from cooperation, which I think is,
I want to think about that more on.
On typicality, that's
exactly what I've done
in all my stuff in the pipeline now.
I'm like, okay, we're
adding a typicality question
in all of the end line surveys,
but more broadly, I wonder.
So, I have this other study with coauthors
about exposure to Hamed Salah
who is an Egyptian
football, soccer superstar
who plays in Liverpool.
And in our survey experiment
there among fans of the club,
we found that the priming
people to really think
about the link between Salah
and Muslims more generally.
So, when we remind them,
like he prays, he fasts,
his daughter's name is Mecca.
His wife wears a headscarf.
Like that was the only
thing that got people
to update positively about
Muslims, more broadly,
as opposed to telling them he's successful
or he's a really nice guy
or these other things.
So, I think there's something to this,
like stressing the link.
Having said that I really struggle
whether you view someone as typical,
is that actually endogenous
to your prejudice?
Like if you say, oh, like I
have a black friend, but like,
oh, they're not like all the
others or something like that.
Like, but isn't your fencing off
of your friend actually
endogenous to your prejudice?
Or is that itself like an
outcome that can be changed?
Like I'm still working
through that conceptually.
- [Woman] Okay.
So, I think that should be for today.
If people want to send
more questions to Salma,
happy to pass them along.
Salma the same (indistinct).